good evening and thank you very much for
joining us
our extraordinary nhs has now succeeded
in vaccinating
more than 17.7 million people across
the uk and nearly a year after this
pandemic began
this unparalleled national effort has
decisively shifted
the odds in our favor so that we no
longer have to rely
simply on lockdowns and restricting our
behavior and putting our lives
on hold but with every day that goes by
this program of vaccination is creating
a shield
around the entire population which means
that we're now traveling
on a one-way road to freedom
and we can begin safely to restart our
lives and do it with confidence
and i want to be frank about exactly
what that means and the
trade-offs involved
the vaccines reduce the danger of covid
they save lives and they keep people
out of hospital but no vaccine against
any disease has ever been 100
effective so whenever we ease
the lockdown whether it's today or in
six or nine months
we've got to be realistic and accept
that there will be more
infections more hospitalizations and
therefore sadly
more deaths just as there are every year
with flu even if we sustain the lockdown
indefinitely which would itself
cost lives and do immeasurable harm to
our children
we would not be able to eradicate this
disease
and that's why it's right gradually to
replace the protection afforded by
the lockdown with the protection of the
vaccines
and our approach is to move with the
utmost care
and advancing in four steps each
with a minimum of five weeks apart so we
can properly judge the impact of each
relaxation before we move on and you can
see the details
of all of this on gov dot uk and we'll
be led
at every stage by data not dates and we
will apply
four tests the pace of the vaccination
program
the effectiveness of the vaccines the
pressure
on the nhs and the risks of any new
variants
of covid and therefore as we look at the
data today i can confirm that two weeks
from today
monday the 8th of march we will begin
step one and schools and colleges across
england
will reopen and teaching classrooms can
start again
all the evidence shows that schools are
safe and the risk posed to children by
covid
is vanishingly small but to offer even
greater
reassurance we're introducing twice
weekly testing
of secondary school and college pupils
and asking them
to wear face coverings for the rest of
this term
students on practical courses can return
to university
but all others will need to continue
learning online and will review the
situation
before the end of the easter holidays
we will allow breakfast and after school
clubs to restart
and among other changes on march the 8th
you'll be able
to have a coffee on a bench or a picnic
in a park
with one person outside your household
and because we know how stressful this
time has been
and how people yearn to see friends and
family
if only fleetingly we will now go
further and on the 29th
of march you can meet more of your
friends and family outside including in
gardens
either as two households or subject
to the rule of six and then
we'll go on to step two which is no
earlier than the 12th
of april and this is a big moment
because shops
will return and reopen hairdressers nail
salons will reopen
pubs and restaurants will all be able to
serve customers
outside precisely because we know that
outside
the risk of transmission is lower
and then five weeks after that no
earlier than may the 17th
we'll go to step three and open all
our hospitality sector to service
indoors
pubs bars restaurants along with hotels
and cinemas and subject to
capacity limits we will also open sports
stadia
concert halls and theaters and finally
provided we continue to pass the four
tests
then from the 21st of june we will go to
step four
and say goodbye to most remaining
restrictions
resuming large-scale events like
business conferences
and football matches lifting the limits
on weddings and reopening nightclubs
all of these steps will apply in england
and the government will continue to do
whatever it takes
to protect jobs and livelihoods
across our whole united kingdom for the
duration of the pandemic
and i know there are some who would like
to accelerate
the timetable i know of course there are
others who would like to be
more cautious and stay in the slow lane
and i understand both points of view and
i sympathize
because levels of infection are still
high
and we must strike a very careful
balance and always accept
that we've got to be humble in the face
of nature
but also we must accept that we cannot
persist
indefinitely with restrictions that have
separated families
and loved ones for too long threatened
the livelihoods
of millions kept pupils out of school
it's thanks to the rollout of these
vaccinations
many of them pioneered in this country
that the balance
of that judgment is now changing in our
favor
and thanks to the vaccinations that
there is
light ahead leading us to a spring and a
summer which i think will be seasons
of hope looking and feeling incomparably
better for us all and from which
we will not go back thank you very much
i'm not going to ask
chris to do the slides thank you prime
minister uh first slide please
um this slide uh which is familiar i
think to anyone who's
watched these uh these press conferences
shows the number of people testing
positive for covert 19 in the uk
uh and as you can see there are
essentially two things to take away from
this
the first of which is that the number
testing positive
has fallen and is continuing to fall
but the second is that the rates are
still very high at uh over 11
000 cases on a seven day average rolling
basis
next slide please
similarly when we look at number of
people in hospital with kovid
in the uk again you can see there is a
significant fall
that is continuing but the rates are
still high
and they're only slightly below the
height of the first peak
we had last year so definitely things
are heading in the right way but
remain at a high level next slide please
and then if we look at the number of
people who have sadly died with uh
following a positive test result for
covert 19
these are also falling and the most
recent seven-day average
is 480 deaths a day
so still high but falling
and falling steadily at this point in
time
next slide please now all of the things
we've seen so far
largely uh are done or probably almost
entirely are done
due to the activities of the general
public uh in the uk and all four nations
in the uk
staying at home and following the
lockdown guidelines
but we have had this really
extraordinary rollout of vaccination
across all four nations of the uk and
you can see
in this graph that this this line is
continuing to go up
steadily day on day next slide please
so i just uh wanted to talk a little bit
about what we would expect
the impact of this to be and the prime
minister has also asked me to talk a bit
about the
results of three studies that were
released today
uh from england and from scotland
so the first thing in this slide uh to
say
is that the great majority uh
well over 90 percent nearer 99
of those who sadly die of kovid
are in the groups the jcvi joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization groups
uh one to nine and they're in the dark
blue and this is a study
of people in hospitals in the uk
and the largest group of those 86
percent
are people who are in groups one to four
these are people
who are over the age of 70 and at this
stage
we have vaccinated the great majority of
people in those groups including in
care and nursing homes who wish to be
vaccinated
a very very high proportion so we
anticipate that
if the vaccines are effective we would
anticipate the death rate will now start
to fall not just because of people
staying home and obeying the lockdown
guidance and instructions
which people are to an extraordinary
degree
but also because of the effects of
vaccination because people have now had
these vaccines
we're now on the middle bar which is
people in groups
ages 50 to 69
already going very rapidly through those
over the age of 65
and people who have significant health
problems
who are under 65 but who we want to
accelerate
the period by which they're vaccinated
so they too are being vaccinated early
on
so this will lead to a significant
further reduction
uh in the risks of people dying and this
also includes
a significant number of people who are
then hospitalized
who are not in the first four groups but
there are people who get severe disease
and are hospitalized
under the age of 50. and it's important
to understand that
we must not leave them behind in
vaccination
because that is that there are still
severe cases
in people who otherwise have no other
health problems
as well as people who got predictable
health problems in hospitals across the
uk
under the age of 50. next slide please
so my final slide is just to make that
point
in a different way and these are data
looking at the proportion of people
admitted to hospital with kovid 19 by
age here in england
and what you can see is people over the
age of 65
the great majority of whom have now been
vaccinated make up
58 percent of those people but people
under 65
make up a very substantial 42 so there's
a lot of people
who would if they got kovid might go on
to develop
severe disease and go into hospital
still unvaccinated and we have quite a
way to go
in all four nations of the uk but making
very fast
progress now how effective are these
vaccines
and that's a question which we said we
think they're effective trials are very
good to date
what we was released today both in
england and in scotland
were three studies which uh tried to
address this problem and this is what
the
prime minister asked me to try to lay
out the first of them
is a study done it called the siren
study
that was done in people who are health
care workers so young
adults under the age of 65 and what that
showed
is that at 21 days there was a 72
percent reduction
uh of the effectiveness of the of the
vaccine uh but the vaccine led to a 72
reduction uh in the number of people who
developed an infection even a mild
infection
at 21 days after just one dose of the
vaccine
and this increased further to 86 if they
had
a second dose so that's extremely good
protection just from mild infection now
obviously you have to have mild
infection to go on to get severe disease
and then the second study which is an
important additional piece of
information
from public health england showed that
you got significant protection also in
older people
including people over the age of 80. so
over 55 or 55
protection just from getting mild
disease
at 35 days but if people got an
infection
there was a further reduction of around
50 in them having severe disease and
therefore going to hospital
so if you put them together you
obviously won't get into hospital if you
don't get disease at all
and then you have a further 50 reduction
so we are confident from these data that
the
the effectiveness of this vaccine in
older people
in reducing hospitalizations is greater
than 75
the exact number will change as the data
comes in
but this we are confident that this is
going to be the case
and this is backed up by a third study
that was released from scotland
and that looked at both the pfizer
vaccine
which is the data i've shown from the uk
so far
and the oxford astrazeneca vaccine and
the headline
numbers they report and to be clear i
think these will change a bit over time
but the headlines that they report is
that the uh probability of
the vaccines reducing your chance of
going to hospital so that's made up of
the reducing the risk of infection and
then reducing the risk of severe disease
both of them together
was 85 for the fisa vaccine
and over 90 percent for the oxford
astrozenica
vaccine and that that was
remained that that vaccine effectiveness
remained uh in those who were 80 years
old
so this tells us three things the first
one is
these vaccines both the vaccines being
used in the uk provide a very
substantial
level of protection from the first dose
and in fact the great majority
protection is
from the first dose so very important
people get their vaccination
secondly the data suggests that that
that protection is
continues over a prolonged period blood
beyond 21 days
so this is uh i think supportive of it
doesn't prove it's exactly right
to be supportive of are delaying the
second dose but importantly the third
thing it shows
is that we must make sure that those
who've had a first vaccine
go on to get their second vaccine
final thing the prime minister asked me
to talk about was the delay of
five weeks between the different stages
of
this uh between the different stages as
they're rolled out the next phases
uh of the roadmap that the prime
minister announced to parliament
today and the reason for that
is that inevitably for each one of these
steps
we are taking a risk which is an
accepted risk
there is a risk to this and everybody in
the country i'm sure understands this
and what we want to do is after each set
of risks with a particular set of
opening up wait until we have data
that tells us has this done what we
expected it to do
have we actually ended up in a slightly
worse place than we thought we would
or have indeed ended up in a slightly
better place but i think
the big worry is have things got
slightly worse than we were expecting
and we cannot measure that in less than
about four weeks
because it takes that long for the
effect to be seen
and the data to come through and be
analyzed so that's the reason
for the five-week gap because it allows
us to see it
whether it's had an effect and then to
make a judgment as to whether that's
material to making the next decision
that's the basis on which this
is done but i think i would like to
re-stress what i said at the beginning
on the first slide there are still very
significant numbers of people
with infections every day in the uk
uh there are still a lot of people in
hospital with this disease this is not
the end but this is
the point where we can have a steady
risk-based
data-driven uh opening up but everybody
must stick to the guidelines
as they go through the different stages
because if we don't do that then we will
get to a stage where the rates go up
very high
and you'll find there are people who are
not protected by the vaccination
these are not 100 effective as the prime
minister said
thank you very much thanks very much
chris patrick anything to
no i completely agree with that and and
the
caution of going every five weeks is
very important because we need to
measure
so that we're not flying blind on this
we need to know what the impact of the
opening up steps are